hey it's Hannah Elliot with Bloomberg
pursuits and we are here today with the
new Mercedes Maybach 600 Pullman today
at the Geneva Motor Show
Mercedes debuted its Maybach s 600
Pullman a stretch sedan that will cost 1
million dollars in its armored form the
car is a new version of the Pullman
Mercedes first debuted in 1963 as a
conveyance for high-ranking monarchs and
heads of state Elvis a king in his own
right owned one so did Coco Chanel and
Elizabeth Taylor these days you might
expect Kanye and Kim to own one or
George and Amal Clooney as they pull up
to the Oscars the new version is based
on the modern s-class sedan but with a
wheelbase that is a full meter longer
than the car it has a 530 horsepower v12
turbocharged engine and refined
suspension and transmission systems to
ensure that any ride in the back of this
goes undisturbed by whatever is
happening outside whether it's hand
grenades or paparazzi inside you can
make the car whatever you want it to be
John Lennon installed a special - sound
system in his during the late 1960s you
on the other hand could add champagne
coolers a theater system a fragrance
system and any number of supple leather
and exotic wood combinations the floor
mats are thick and plush and the windows
cancel out virtually all exterior noise
and harmful UV rays the quilted
stitching on the dashboard and the
center armrest alone is far superior to
the entire interior of lesser vehicles
and if you haven't guessed the back is
big enough for three rows of seats or a
lay flat lounger you decide this is man
Hannah Elliot with lewbert suits and
new Mercedes mailbox 600